I always curious about the editing
process in every movie because it's the
final rewrite I'm curious how when you
go to the editing room with all your
footage what surprised you
what made you nervous you know it all
surprised me you're right it really does
evolve you know there's writing the
script there's shooting the movie then
there's the editing process which is
that the final rewrite of the film and
it's so funny the things I think are
gonna work sometimes don't work at all
the things I think there's no way it's
gonna work end up being the favorite
scenes the mr. mime scene which you know
I fought really hard to put into the
movie and then Justin I were just
talking about the other day after we
shot it we're like this this is insane
and then we have to cut it I tried to
cut it the Pierce was like are you crazy
you can't cut the scene and we put
together and it's one of those scenes
that just everyone loves so how long was
your first cut compared to the finished
filming I don't do very long cut so I
actually keep it really tight so it
actually expands after my first place I
go really really tight
and then and then open it up and let it
breathe will you have deleted scenes on
here yes they're still the attends we
just finished that like three weeks ago
I figured it's always right when the
movies about to come out 20 minutes for
fans can they expect of the deleted
scenes quite a bit and there's a there's
a whole different version of the first
act in the Glee scenes it's it's
fascinating um
that's awesome prevents yeah I mean
listen just just fully exposed here we
just show everything no completely um
what was it what what do you think it is
about the film for fans and non-fans
that they can look forward to because
obviously a lot of people know Pokemon
but there's still a ton of people that
have never seen it yeah well first of
all we we dedicated maybe to the fans
there's there's the new generation of
fans but there's also the older
generation and I was surprised myself
how much Millennials adore this
20-something
grew up with it if you love it and so we
wanted to you know it's a love letter to
fans of broken model but it's also a
human story an amazing journey and it's
funny rinds hilarious and just as
incredible Catholic rebel and and the
emotional ride of it in the heart of it
I think is appealing to everyone whether
they know Pokemon or not getting Ryan is
a huge deal because I mean everything
I've seen of the footage is he's awesome
what was your reaction when you found
out that Ryan had agreed to do it huge
relief I mean we were we were all laying
on Ryan so what happened was I did I did
these tests so I took it on flip Ryan's
from a different movie
and the second I saw in the test it was
done I mean it's perfect and we hadn't
even reached out to him and there would
be no other version in my mind so what
he finally said yes it's just this
massive sigh of relief and then I found
out the other day he finally confessed
he showed that clip to his daughter and
she's the one who talked him into it so
so thank you to Ryan's daughter
that's amazing yes I'm sure a lot to
talk about like video game movies and
video game movies purses if you will you
consider Pokemon a video game movie like
you know about that people have said
that stuff yeah
I'm trying to have to think about the
curse part before the movie comes up I'm
nervous enough yeah people have said
that but you know at the end of the day
this is a character out of the larger
Pokemon universe and for people don't
realize Pokemon has been around for over
20 years
there's maybe over 20 seasons I'm don't
don't don't moment to that of television
shows there's there's over 20 animate
enemies so there's plenty of storylines
related to Pokemon not just the video
games it's a broad universe and the
detective Pikachu video game that this
was based on which is
has this really incredible human story
to it that when I was told about it just
had made a lot of sense as a film and we
really you know tried to embrace you
know the human side of the story and and
craft a compelling story with a lot of
heart and a great character last
question for you on the VFX what was was
there a shot or two there like we're
never getting this there's a lot you
know the visual effects are really
incredible in this they're massive but
ultimately it's the it's the subtle
scenes that I love the most it's just
the scenes of Pikachu and Tim talking
and sitting and having sharing a coffee
at a bar are so amazing to me is they're
so organic and natural and really you
feel like people choose actually there
it feels like you know we shot the film
with Pikachu already in it and we shot
on film we've used old lenses we have
it's a very gritty organic look to the
film there's very little grain screen
and it's all location
footage so so it's got a very
interesting look that makes the Pokemon
comes right